71 the professional helps others
when i first finished the manuscript for
gates of fire
it was 800 pages long my agent sterling
lord though he loved it
said he couldn't submit it to publishers
unless i cut at least 300 pages
that was like telling me to amputate not
one limb but two
i was devastated one of the people
sterling had shown the manuscript to was
tom ginsberg
who had been head of viking press for
years it was a hell of a thing for
someone of tom's stature simply to
glance at an unknown writer's work
but tom did more he sent me a note
i still have it the central sentence
said
there's something great in here steve i
have confidence that you will find it
and bring it out
i barely knew tom and he barely knew me
but if you saw the thumbprints i put on
that note from the dozens of times i
picked it up and
hung onto its words for inspiration you
would think we were the best of buds
from way back
the amateur hoards his knowledge and his
reinforcement
he believes if he shares what he
possesses with others he will lose it
the professional is happy to teach he
will gladly lend a hand or deliver a
swift kick
but there's a caveat the professional
refuses to be iconized
not for selfish reasons but because he
knows how destructive the dynamic of
iconization is
to the iconizer the pro will share his
wisdom
with other professionals or with
amateurs who are committed to becoming
professionals
like art in roseanne cash's dream he
will not waste his time on dilettantes